PLAY, PLAY COMPETITIVELY THE
BEST THAT YOU CAN.
>> Chris: AND HOW ABOUT TWO THEW
IT WILL CHANGE SOMEE
IS MARK PYSYK GOING BACK INTO
THE LINEUP FOR IN THE THIRD PE Y
WILL HAVE TO CONTEND
TORONTO AND SPEZZA, A GREAT PLAY
HERE ON THE WING N NET THISET UE
DIFFERENTTN FRONT AND
MAKES THAT STOP.
>> Craig: ANOTHER ADJAND
NEGATE THE ICING.
DAHLIN SAVE.
>> Craig: GOOD PLAY,
RIELLY NOW BACK AHEAD TOECE! WIS
NOT SCORED IN THE LAST FOUR BUT
PRIOR TO THAT,
A GLOVE STOP BY ANDERSON AND
THAT IS AS G BUT TO
SMILE AT THAT, AN EXCELLENT SHOT
AND AN EVENIN FRONT AND IT IS KK
APPROACHING, TSURPRISING LILJEGN
BUT NOT TOO MANY OUT.
>> Craig: AND THE REBOUND WITH A
CHANCE THERE.
KERFOOT THOUGHT THAT HE JUMPINGN
AND GETTING INVOLVED IN THE PLAY
OUT ALONG WITH THOMPSON AT THE
MOMENT.
AN THE OUTSIDEK
HOCKEY BUT --
>> Craig: THAT WOULD BE A GOOD S
TIME SURROUNDED BY SABRES WITH
BUFFAL AND A
GOOD STICK THERE, IT IS HOLL
E TE
BLOCK.
>> WOO-HOO!
>> LET'S ONE AND
SANDIN THERE, MAYBE THOUGHT THAT
RIELLY WAS THIS BUT THE ONLY GUN
FAVOUR OF THES ASPLUND AND
A TOE STOP THERE.
BUT ANOTHER PENALTY IS LYUBUSHK.
>> Craig: THAT WAS CLOSE.
>> Chris: THE HORN ENDING THE
FIRST HALF OF NET AND KYLE DUBA.
>> Chris: THEY NEED EVIDENCE NOW
NYLANDER HAS TOERE, HITTING